hey dr. Berg in this short video I want
to cover a very important point that
keeps coming up over and over and over
again
I'm dr. Berg I don't want to take
cruciferous because someone told me on
the internet that if I take cruciferous
that my thyroid will become a problem
and I'll get a big huge goiter well the
chances of that happening are much less
than winning the Virginia Lottery it's
just very very very rare and it would
take tremendous amounts of cruciferous
vegetables over many years without
eating anything else to create that
situation so yes it is true that some
cruciferous vegetables will have a
tendency to lock up or deplete your
iodine and the thyroid needs iodine to
work but you would have to consume a lot
so a little bit is going to be fine and
the reason why I always recommend this
is because one of the real root causes
of a slow thyroid is too much estrogen
in that that's locked up in the far
right either from having a pregnancy or
from the environment or from an
overactive ovary or from a fibroid and
so all that estrogen is what's really
causing a destruction of the thyroid yet
we need to balance that so we need to
consume the cruciferous to balance the
source of that because it's not real
it's not true that the thyroid problems
out there nowadays are coming from a
lack of iodine and that's why you can
take all the iodine you want in the
world and you probably won't see any
change it'll probably very expensive
urine because it's going to go right
through you
so we need that understanding of what's
causing this problem and some other
videos I talked about the cause but in
this video we're just going to touch on
you don't have to be too scared about
this and also if you take a little bit
of iodine let's say you took cruciferous
I haven't concentrate this is called
whole cruciferous food I have broccoli
cabbage asparagus kale in here radish
and then I put seek help in here to add
as a anti or a anti goiter or basically
just
apply some iodine to prevent any loss
from the cruciferous food so you can
also eat those vegetables and create the
same effect but cruciferous is actually
totally fine including that kale shake
that we recommend as well thanks for
watching I'll see in the next video